madame monsieur bonsoir à tous une
ouverture des archives annoncée hilaire
à par catherine trautmann ministre de
la culture devrait permettre de faire la
vérité sur cette nuit du 17 octobre 61
oui mais les infestations d'algériens
durement réprimées a fait de
nombreuses victimes jamais
comptabilisés dans les bilans officiels
sa décision de lever le secret sur des
documents qui dorment depuis 36 ans si
c'est des réactions mitigées des
syndicats de police reste que cette
décision donnera en même temps un
nouvel éclairage sur la responsabilité
de maurice papon alors préfet de police
philippe boiseries valérie fournier
ouvrir les archives il est aussi facile
de le dire que mal essayé de le faire
les portes de notre mémoire on la
réputation d'être levée
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'une page
sombre de notre histoire
les questions sur ce 17 octobre 1961
sont dures
y at-il eu lors de cette manifestation
du fln contre le couvre-feu imposé aux
algériens et pour l'algérie
indépendante trois morts selon le bilan
officiel ou 200 ans et plus selon les
travaux récents d'historiens
y at-il eu volonté politique ou non de
réprimer qui est responsable la police
le préfet le gouvernement
les premières réactions sur cette
ouverture des archives celle des
syndicats de policiers sans partager
voir opposer c'est la police nationale
qui est mieux
pas toutes au moins c'est ce qu'il
ressentait qui est mise en cause et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui pour moi ma
connaissance en plus chaque jeu la
police nationale a de quoi que ce soit
cette institution qui fonctionne tout à
fait démocratiquement et qui est
véritablement une institution
républicaine et le vide par mois
d'autant plus mal je crois que quand on
pratique le culte du secret
quand on ne dit pas les choses c'est que
ça cache quelque chose or je pense que
nous avons seulement une à cacher
n'avons pas à rougir de la police
nationale n'auront pas à rougir de
notre nation me porte à rougir de la
république française
un débat exacerbée par le procès de
maurice papon le préfet de police de
l'époque
hier car meissner ministre des armées
en 1861 le dédouaner de toute
responsabilité aujourd'hui celui-ci
applaudi à l'ouverture des archives
rappelle le climat de l'époque celui de
la guerre d'algérie
et apporte un bémol sur les
responsabilités
à la responsabilité de la décision m
réagir fermement on a quand même joué
sa chance et la responsabilité du
gouvernement et aucun doute
merci du les bavures chez nous aussi la
responsabilité du gouvernement chivu et
mon corps ne répondait plus c'est tout
autre chose
mais pour savoir qu'il faut trouver les
archives notamment celle de la
préfecture de police
or celles-ci sont légalement protégé
jusqu'en 2021 il faudra donc des
circulaires peut-être des lois
et puis il faudra regrouper les
documents disséminés dans les
différents services de police que
donneront ces services aux archives la
vérité et sans doute au bout d'un
chemin encore très torture